zuerst einmal gilt ja seit februar märz
tatsächlich die verpflichtung zur
quarantäne bei einreise aus
risikogebieten verpflichtung dass keine
bitte sondern staatliche anordnung durch
verordnungen der bundesländer
und tatsächlich gibt es auch
stichprobenartige kontrollen wie das bei
anderen verpflichtungen auch ist diese
sollen noch verstärkt werden indem zum
beispiel die aussteige karten nicht nur
auf papier und händisch dann auch für
die stichproben-kontrollen genutzt
werden können sondern das bundeskabinett
hat just vor wenigen minuten beschlossen
das unter federführung des
innenministeriums mit unserer
tatkräftigen unterstützung wir eben auch
zu einer stärkeren digitalisierung in
diesem bereich kommen um die
gesundheitsämter vor ort zu entlasten
und das jetzt auch zügig umsetzen
es gilt übrigens auch schon seit monaten
die verpflichtung auch das will ich noch
mal ausdrücklich sagen und gerne
sie bitten uns weiter zu tragen die
verpflichtung für einreisende aus
risikogebieten sich aktiv bei ihrem
wohnsitz gesundheitsamt oder dem
gesundheitsamt des zielortes zu melden
dass man eingereist ist aus einem
risikogebiet